ccsd is giving more support to their  students a new district-wide initiative  was announced today to give 24-7 virtual  tutoring and academic support to  students in the area the district  partnered with the company paper which  helps with more than 200 subject areas  in different languages the ceo of paper  says this platform will help curb the  gap of learning that was missed during  the pandemic last year  everything the pandemic's thrown at  teachers has made it really challenging  a resource like paper is not there to  replace the teacher in any way it's  there to support them instead of getting  a text message from your student or an  email from your students at 10 pm at  night you actually will be able to push  them towards a resource like paper and  say hey you have someone who can support  you with your subjects  every tutor on the platform is highly  trained and background checked it's also  a completely free service given to k-12  students and families